souvent mais un peu de temps à retrouver
les origines et à retrouver d'où ça
vient
et moi je trouve que la conclusion
intéressante si l'objectif est de se
dire qu'il faut éviter que ça se
reproduise c'est effectivement un but
très noble et tout le monde partage
ben justement est ce que est ce que le s
que du coup il faut se dire il faut
fermer les laboratoires ou est ce que
parce que même si ce même si ça s'était
échappé d'un laboratoire dont je me dis
il n'empêche que dans la nature ça se
produit aussi on a des exemples
historiques en a pas mal et du coup il
vaut mieux anticiper un petit peu et
préparé mais dans ce cas là il faudrait
choisir lé strict des normes plus
strictes pour les laboratoires être plus
sûr faire attention à ce qu'on fait or
pour l'instant de ce que je veux c'est
des p4 je n'ai pas été déçue du one j'ai
pas visité de mes yeux etc
mais c'est extrêmement difficile qu'il y
ait des problèmes sur les laboratoires
de cette haute sécurité
il ya par exemple une histoire une
fausse rumeur qui circule énormément sur
un sdf qui se seraient introduits dans
un p4 en france à lyon alors
effectivement il ya un sdf qui s'est
introduit dans dans le laboratoire p4
entre guillemets mais c'est dans la
partie administrative n'a jamais eu
accès dans les zones zones dangereuses
il a été tout de suite confrontées pour
y avait tout de suite une personne qui
l'a vu ça n'a duré que quelques minutes
du français ça n'a rien à voir et c'est
des endroits qui sont extrêmement
sécurisé aussi bien contre l'intrusion
mais aussi contre l'échappement de toute
molécule c'est des niveaux de sécurité
qui sont d'un très très beaux standards
c'est extrêmement difficile que j'aie
quelque chose s'échappe d'un laboratoire
je pense que c'est plutôt elle aussi une
hypothèse de liés aux laboratoires c'est
ce qui est plutôt une hypothèse de type
zone ce qui se serait produit à la
collecte et la collecte c'est moins
fréquent qui est des collectes qu' il ya
des interactions entre l'homme et
l'animal
coty sont quotidiennes dans le monde
avec plein d'élevage intensif comme
problème de ce type là donc moi je pense
que même même si on cherche encore à
savoir d'où ça vient même si on peut
continuer à chercher la réponse on peut
déjà répondre à cette question là
[Musique]